Speaker 1: OK.
Why don't we let's talk to someone else, right?
I mean, why not?
Let's go to the state of Texas and talk to
Quincy from Texas.
Quincy, you're on the air.
Speaker 8: Oh gosh damn, I didn't expect to
get on.
OK.
Well, anyways, I was sort of curious.
You know, I have a very difficult time sort
of empathizing with like viewpoints of conservatives.
OK.
It just seems like, you know, the more you
take a more empirical view on the world, the
more you learn about history.
You just can't sign off to a lot of these
things that, like conservatives worry about,
like they worry about, you know, like like
not changing race policy, even though we have
like a history of basically oppressing races,
right?
Like, I just I just think that conservative
is just like conservatism is just like dumb
Speaker 5: overall, OK?
It just doesn't.
Speaker 1: You're losing.
It sounds like you're losing pace.
You're losing patience for ignorance and stupidity,
it sounds like.
Speaker 8: Yeah, I just I don't know, I just
feel like it's still less less intelligent
position and like it's not really set to like
stand the course of time, really.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, here's what I would
say to that without like arguing or debating
the merits of this, because this is a very
it's a very surface level argument.
Conservatives are just dumb.
Let's skip the argument.
I think my response to you would be, Hey,
you know what?
Just calling people dumb, whether they are
or aren't, probably isn't really going to
achieve the change that we want.
And so we need to think of what we can do.
Like, let's say, maybe that's true or maybe
they're not dumb, but they're just wrong or
whatever, right?
Either way, we need to find some way to realize
and deal with the fact that these folks are
a big part of American society and we have
problems to solve regardless.
And how can we actually do it?
And it's not by just calling them dumb, so
I think I would take like a more pragmatic
approach.
Speaker 5: OK, I see what you mean.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Are you clicking a pen or what is that noise?
Are you clicking a pen open and show?
Speaker 8: It's it's a butterfly knife.
Speaker 1: You're opening and closing a knife.
OK?
Yes.
All right, good, well, listen, I'm going to
let you go, let's continue to think about
this issue.
I think that there's a lot to it and the only
caller I'm aware of that was doing knife play
during a phone call that we had.
Let's go next to Mike, the new dad, Mike.
The new dad is on the air.
Speaker 5: Mike?
Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you.
How are you doing, man?
Good.
Congratulations on being a new dad.
Speaker 5: Thank you.
I just wanted to say, I appreciate you kind
of covering the Pete Food Judge thing and
sort of trying to normalize paternity leave
for four new dads.
I kind of thought it was a bit of a joke,
but I'm being a new dad and actually being
on it.
I found it quite beneficial since my wife
kind of wrapped up her maternity leave and
I've had this time to bond with with my daughter.
Speaker 1: Are you?
Do you get paid paternity leave or you're
just allowed to take time off but unpaid?
Speaker 5: Yeah, no, it's it's paid.
So if you live in or work in the state of
New York, basically how it works is in the
state will cover 60 percent of your your pay.
But a new policy like my company had this
year was they just give you 100 percent of
your pay and benefits while you're out on
paternity leave.
So it's a total of 12 weeks.
So it works out to works out to be three months,
and you just have to use it within the first
year of of your of your child that date your
child's born so you could take it in two week
increments all at once.
However, you kind of want to split it up,
but essentially, like my company actually
found out, is only like even though they're
giving me a hundred percent of my pay, they're
only responsible for 40.
The remaining 40 percent,
Speaker 1: that was going to be my question.
That was going to be our question.
Are they just matching up to that last 40
percent?
Yeah.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
So they just match up to the last 40 percent.
So I mean it it's interesting that more companies
kind of don't do it.
Like if you work for a bigger business, considering
they're they're only on the hook for the the
remaining 40 percent.
And I mean, I'm not an accountant, but I'm
I'm sure there's some way that they're going
to be able to write off some of that with
with me not technically working, but but yeah.
Speaker 1: And how much sleep are you getting?
Unidentified: Oh.
Oh, boy.
Speaker 1: You just cut out, Mike, unfortunately,
it sounded like you were trying to answer,
but you just completely cut out.
Oh, boy.
All right, Mike, congratulations, it sounds
like the connection is degenerating very,
very quickly.
So we're going to the congratulations, and
I hope that the answer to how much sleep you're
getting is a lot.
I hope it's a lot.
Let's go next to Paul Garcia from Mexico.
Speaker 5: Hi.
Hello.
Um, I don't know, I guess I just wanted your
thoughts on a good book like good politics
book that they teach me like, you know, background
from conservatives in, you know, new ground
for progressives to get into COVID.
Speaker 1: That's a great question.
You know, I don't read any political books,
so I'm like the worst person to ask because
I get so much politics in my job.
I read history.
I read technology.
Speaker 5: I read you have a narrative book
like Friends Revolution or something like
that.
Speaker 1: French Revolution.
No, I really don't know.
French Revolution.
I've not.
I don't know.
You know what I would do for all these things.
If you just Google best book about the French
Revolution, I guarantee you you will find
great recommendations.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I've looked at a few because
they saved the French Revolution to kick start
the whole revolution thing in the world.
I just find it interesting.
I just wanted to know.
I am just listening.
That was my only question.
Oh, okay.
Speaker 1: The key part of the Mexico, it
is the issue.
Speaker 5: Why?
Why are Chihuahua colonized?
Speaker 1: No, no, no.
Speaker 5: We won't eat them chihuahua or
eat up at all.
I simply want a free kick to come on your
show.
Even more so.
Speaker 1: Well, that's like 67 degrees.
That's not that.
No. 18 is like 66 or something, isn't it?
Yeah.
You know, something like that.
That's not bad.
That's not bad for almost November.
Speaker 5: Well, yeah, that's that's the CDC.
Well, our belief in our town apart.
OK.
It's like 16 14 Celsius.
Speaker 1: OK, got it.
Where did you learn English?
Speaker 5: My whole life, I, I, I have taken
English from preschool, elementary and middle
school high school.
Wow.
Speaker 1: Well, you speak excellent English,
my friend.
Speaker 5: Well, thank you.
I really was fishing for that.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, Paul.
Great to hear from you.
Speaker 5: Yeah, you too.
Take care.
Keep the
Speaker 1: good work.
Thank you.
There's Paul Garcia from Chez Wawa in Mexico.
Love it.
Why don't we speak to, you know, there's a
lot of the phone lines are packed today.
It's actually crazy.
What's going on?
Why don't we go to Ryan from Newfoundland?
Ryan from Newfoundland, you're on the air,
my friend.
Last chance, Ryan from Newfoundland to unmute
yourself.
All right, that's too bad, I was really hoping
to hoping to hear from that